hello my name is barbara kratz fortini
and i'm an assistant professor of
genetics and a program director at the
keck graduate institute
school of pharmacy and health sciences
in claremont california
welcome to my classroom also known as my
home office
i would like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to give this
talk on genomics education then this was
long before all of higher education
profoundly changed
due to the coronavirus i think it's
important to keep a few of my slides
that i've prepared
but also talk about how this will impact
what we're doing now and in the future
so the title of my talk is priming the
precision medicine pipeline
new models for applied genomics
education and i'd like to address
what it's going to take to make
precision medicine standard of care
from the perspective of providing enough
trained clinicians
to be in every clinic hospital
in every community across the united
states
and eventually around the world
so a brief outline of my talk i'll start
with the current applied genomics
pipeline
then the skills and knowledge domains
we've identified is important in applied
genomics
next i'll talk about a new program we've
started at kgi
which is a master of science in human
genetics and genomic data analytics
and i'll finish up with some additional
educational models
for genomics training that are coming in
the future
of course i am an educator so we have
learning objectives
the three learning objectives for this
talk are to identify the primary skills
and knowledge domains
and apply genomics training programs to
recognize
challenges in applied genomics education
in the current environment
and to appreciate opportunities to
expand the genomics expertise pipeline
into populations that you might not be
thinking of
so let's start by talking about who is
currently working in precision medicine
i think if you're tuning into this
conference you believe
that genetics and genomics are going to
change
everything about healthcare in the
future and i would agree with you
but one of the issues that is holding
the industry back
is the lack of trained experts
according to the statistics on the
american board of medical
specialties of the more than 900 000
board certified physicians
less than 3 000 are certified
in medical genetics and genomics
according to a survey that was published
last year in genetics and medicine
from 2015 data more than 30 percent of
geneticists said that
new patients had to wait more than three
months for a non-emergency appointment
and of course that was five years ago i
can only imagine what it is today
outside of physicians of course the
need for genetic counselors is growing
uh 27 is the estimate in the next decade
and
then of course there are merging careers
that we have no data for
but just looking at job postings things
like
variant interpretation specialists
genomic scientists
etc continue to grow
so where are these genomic specialists
coming from well first i'll talk about
the phd track i am a phd i have a phd in
biology from caltech and i was trained
to do basic research
and that pipeline i would say has served
the united states extremely well
the advances in basic and applied
genomics has enabled all of this
actionability
and i will say even though there are
some threats to this system
due to the coronavirus and some of the
economic consequences
we're very good at making phds that can
make these fundamental discoveries
and so a lot of phds are going to go
into basic and applied research that
will continue to push forward the
boundaries of what we can do
thinking of getting into the clinic
however
a lot of phds do not go that route
who does go into the clinic well of
course we have medical doctors
but again that's a small percentage of
the total
md graduates in the united states end up
working in genetics
an increasing number of nurse
practitioners are specializing in
genetics
and of course we have genetic counselors
i came into this world through genetic
counseling
kgi decided to start a genetic
counseling program
to address the profound shortage in
genetic counselors
especially on the west coast of the
united states and
i was recruited to help teach genetics
and genomics in this program
and it really got me interested in this
field of genetic counseling
which i admit i knew very little about
at the time
and one of the things that makes it an
exciting career choice is that you don't
have to go into clinical practice there
are roles for genetic counselors in the
genomics industry
at testing companies and development of
new tests and in drug development
but that means that a large percentage
of people every year who graduate with a
genetic counseling degree
don't end up working in clinical
practice for their entire careers
which means the pipeline is further
narrowed
we also have people who contribute to
this industry with other
graduate degrees like bioinformatics
also have biostatistics
but again these experts are not going
into clinical practice
so how do we change the balance of these
arrows not
by reducing who is going into the
genomics industry
or the drug development path but by
expanding the total number of people
going into applied genomics
i'll start by talking a little bit about
the institution i'm a part of and that's
kgi i assume that a lot of you have
never heard of us
um we're very small and we're relatively
young in the higher education space
founded just in 1997 kgi was however
founded specifically
for the applied life sciences so we're a
graduate level
institution and all of our programs are
either health science or life science
but we do try to be very responsive to
industry
and to healthcare settings we're the
youngest of
the seven claremont colleges in
claremont california and you see a
lovely picture here of our campus and
the mountains that are nearby
we're divided into two schools the henry
e riggs school of applied life sciences
houses the original programs and that's
our phd in applied life science the
master of business and science
masters of engineering and bioprocessing
and then
other master of science programs and our
certificate programs
we also have a school of pharmacy and
health sciences
that was built in the last few years for
an innovative pharmd curriculum
and once the pharmd program was up and
running
the leadership decided to look into
genetic counseling
and that's when i came to kgi to help
with the
establishment of our genetics programs
to teach
human genetics and human genomics and in
the process of starting the genetic
counseling
program the leadership had this crazy
idea to also start a companion program
in genomic data analytics to really be
out there meeting the need of the jobs
of the future and i'll talk about how we
structure that
unless we have an occupational therapy
program coming soon
some of you may know that we are also in
the process of starting the school of
medicine
it'll be very exciting to see how that
develops in the next couple years
one thing that's really important to
know about kgi is that
innovation is our motto
so innovators start here is the tagline
on all of our
banners and campus materials
and it really is um
understanding at kgi that we really want
to be
near the cutting edge and to create new
models in education
so how do we do this in the space of
genomics
well we wanted to take a full spectrum
approach
there is the traditional way at kga of
course we have these two masters
programs
and so we can admit small cohorts of
students
and get them graduate degrees but that's
not the only way we can expand the
pipeline
so starting on the left side of the
screen we have
initiatives to help increase
interest in high school now i made this
arrow a little bit smaller because we
don't have to do much work in that
field right now i think just the way
society has embraced
genetic testing and the power of
genomics
a lot of young people already want to go
into
precision medicine and so the only thing
we need to do is expose them to all of
the careers
that are involved in that if they don't
want to go to medical school
how can they play a role in this
exciting part of
health science and of course some are
immersion programs to get
students the expertise they'll need to
get into undergraduate programs which
will then
build on their talents in the
undergraduate sphere
we do have a summer immersion program at
kgi of course this summer it will not be
in person
but again we also want to expose
undergrads to
careers in genomics that maybe aren't as
traditional
as being a doctor or a nurse
very few undergraduates have ever heard
of genetic counseling or even
the genomics industry and so giving them
the opportunity to just see the options
is one part of providing students for
the pipeline
now of course kgi is a graduate
institution so we do award master's
degrees
and we have two of these programs the
gen ed counseling program and the
genomic data analytics program
that provide clinicians and
support services to the genomics
industry
but we also know a lot of people are
going to get into this pipeline
through a traditional medical school
experience
and it's important that we now integrate
genetics and genomics
into medical school education so it
comes as second nature
when a doctor is handed a genetics
report
the biggest audience however though are
the people that are already there
and these are people who are working
clinicians either genetic counselors
nurses doctors that want more genetics
and genomics expertise
including people who work in industry
and want to better serve
the precision medicine workforce and so
we will address this with executive
education programs
and continuing education workshops just
building
that expertise at all levels
and so that is the full spectrum
approach
so what kind of skills do we want an
an ideal applied genomics expert
well when we set out to design our
programs i did a lot of interviews
with people working in the industry side
and clinical sites
in genomics testing companies just to
get a handle on what
their perfect new employee would be
and we kept coming back to these three
core domains
the first is just genetics knowledge
that
is why genetic counselors can get jobs
all throughout the industries because
people are very interested
in experts that know genetics through
and through understanding
genomics now with all the fundamental
insights we've learned in the last few
years
as an appreciation for human variation
that is up to date on what we know on
structural variation
on common variation on rare variants
and again on the impact of ancestry
and our current limitations and
data from multi-ethnic cohorts
the next big skill set
was in data science so these are
hands-on skills the ability to have some
knowledge of command line programming
to be able to do data analytics and to
also
work in this space managing files in a
hipaa compliant way
of course in genomics we have very large
files sometimes
that we want to stay with the patient so
really understanding how you manage this
information on a practical
level and the last domain is something
that comes up
at kgi in all of our programs
and that's just what it takes to be an
effective co-worker
in the current state of
the economy and that is someone who has
great communication skills
who understands how to work in a team
has strong ethics
and all of the skills that go along with
being
a professional
so at kgi we decided to address these
three
core areas with a new program a master
of human genetics and genomic data
analytics
and i always point out to our students
that the first part is the master of
human genetics
it is a master of science and we really
want the students to fundamentally
understand
human genetics we also want them to
understand
the applied life sciences and really
benefit from kgi's long track record in
that space
and to have this innovative human
genomics curriculum
that is on the leading edge trying to
figure out what is going to be important
in five to ten years when they're still
in practice
that we're only learning about today
a highlight of this program is the
ability to work side by side with our
future genetic counselors and our
applied life science students as
students excuse me well they're gaining
all of this hands-on experience
but they're also building up their
professional network and really
understanding
the roles and needs of people they will
interact with but are in different
professions
and last we want to make sure our
graduates have this foundation in
genetics and genomics but
have an ability to translate that to an
actionable clinical recommendation
and really be the person that's the
between the research scientist
and the clinical practitioner
so how did we structure this program
well it is a 20-month 21-month two-year
program
we have our core genetics courses that
they take alongside the genetic
counseling students
then we have the applied life science
courses that are
based on previous kgi offerings and we
have a summer internship where
the students get hands-on practice
doing all of these skills and then in
the second year we have specialty
courses in genomic data analytics
and the students have the opportunity to
pick a concentration
our three concentrations are clinical
decision support
clinical trial design and assay
development
and last the students do a capstone
project in collaboration with an outside
either medical center or
research institute or industry site to
develop a showcase of their skills
these are the courses that we put
together for our
two-year program everyone in our program
takes
these courses in the first year we're
very heavy in just the basics
of genetics and
analytical skills so in the first
semester the students will be taking
a full course in human molecular
genetics and genetic disease mechanisms
but they'll also be taking programming
for the biosciences which is a class
taught in python we also do teach just
the basics of working in the command
line
and connecting to remote servers other
skills
that will help them use programs built
by others
in the second semester they get an
entire semester of human genomics
that's coupled with a human genomics lab
uh we do have uh midnight on sequencer
so we do long read sequencing
we use publicly available data to do
a trio analysis with short read
sequencing
they get expertise going from fast queue
files all the way to variant call
files and then interpreting variants
using the acmg guidelines
they also have courses in clinical
cancer genomics medical genetics and
biochemical genetics and that really
is the foundation of all of their
knowledge they will take forward
at the same time they're doing those
courses in the first year they're also
doing their applied life science
curriculum
so they do take a course in medical
diagnostics
to really understand where this data
comes from
they take the introduction to bioscience
industry to understand
how this industry works and what their
role will be
they do take clinical biostats and
healthcare ethics
and they also get the opportunity to
take a biomedical data systems and
informatics class
which also includes transcriptomics and
this is of course taught in the
programming language r
and they take a clinical trial design
and literature evaluation course to
start learning how to read clinical
literature as opposed to just
basic science literature so in the
first year curriculum we really give
them a strong foundation and they take
that into their summer internship
and then they come back the second year
and a lot of their time is spent on
their capstone project
six units each semester but they also
have the second year curriculum
that we've designed specifically for
roles that we think are
very important in the future and the
first is a full semester in dna
sequencing and variant analysis
really teaching the students how to use
the
clinical guidelines to understand
variants that they find
in patients we also have a course in
functional genomics
where they learn a lot of the research
side
techniques including chromatin
confirmation capture
and other things that i think are fun
but the students
might interact with later if these
become useful
to the clinical space
we also have a course that is called
genomic knowledge translation and this
is really a communications class
because we have spent two years filling
their heads with lots of very technical
knowledge
they then need to know how to give this
information back to a variety of
audiences
in a way that is digestible so we do
have a course
that does talk about presenting their
information
in a variety of formats unless we have a
genomic data visualization and
management course
and this also reinforces their skills
in file management and programming so
this course
uses both r and python and really
sets them up for working in a hipaa
compliant way
now we have another
course in pharmacogenomics and advanced
pharmaceutical discovery that we do in
the second year
and this really leverages the fact that
the students are
in the school of pharmacy and a lot of
them are interested in how
genomics is changing drug development
and
this course really highlights the
um changes in our field there
now i did mention each student does get
the opportunity to pick a concentration
we have three to choose from the first
concentration was
clinical decision support this is really
how we built the program
thinking about the ideal education to be
a variant curator
and for those students who really want
to go that route
we picked from our other existing
courses at kgi
to offer molecular basis of disease
medical terminology advanced writing
we do have some fundamental papers
classes applied medicine
but i'll highlight two courses in this
track and the first is our human
embryology and prenatal diagnosis
this course is required for our genetic
counseling students but is not required
for the genomic data analytics students
but a lot of our gda students felt that
it was very useful for understanding
um genetics and how this plays out in
human beings and so that is a very
popular elective
the other course i wanted to point out
was our machine learning and the life
sciences course
and this is for our students who have
the programming skills and interest to
really
learn how machine learning can help
automate
in the future a lot of the things we do
by hand today
and i think it'll be an incredible skill
set to bring to any
position where we're increasingly seeing
ai
help speed along workflows
and do first pass interpretation
when we were building the msgda
degree we did get a lot of input from
one of our partners at amgen and
they were telling us how important
genetics now is in the clinical trial
development aspect of the pharmaceutical
industry
and the need for trained genetics
professionals in that space
and so for people interested in going
into drug development
and pharmacogenomics we put together
these courses from
our existing offerings first of course
is the introduction to food and drug law
i think the fda
policies for genetic testing and test
development have never been
in the news more so i anticipate this
course is going to be very popular in
the fall
but these issues are important to know
if you plan on developing
the next great pharmaceutical or
even a genetic test then kgi does have
our courses in pharmaceutical discovery
and development
and design of clinical trials
the last uh concentration that we came
up with was assay development these are
for our true
entrepreneurs and there's a very
entrepreneurial spirit at kgi
and so for those students who have taken
all this information and have a great
idea for a new product
we wanted them to know what it would
take to bring it to market
and so this puts together some of our
business and science courses
including the food and drug law and our
advanced in vitro diagnostics business
operations
and again some of the fundamental papers
just to understand what is actually
needed in the field
so these are our three concentrations i
will say most of our students so far
have chosen the clinical decision
support pathway
and for those working in precision
medicine i think this
is the pathway that best um
captures the skills knowledge and
expertise
that will be needed to be an effective
precision medicine specialist
now the heart of our program is actually
what happens when the students are off
campus
and that's the summer experience because
i think
nothing helps the students really
understand what all of this didactic
coursework means
than seeing it put into practice so all
of our students complete a summer
internship at either a clinical genomics
lab
a company a research center
below you see the place where our first
cohort spent their summer
so we had students at labcorp by marin
st
jude scripps translational merck and the
nih
and this experience really gave all of
our students
an insight into what skills were really
used day-to-day
and why they needed to know all those
things that i told them that they needed
to know
and we hope that the summer experience
translates into their capstone project
as i said in the second year the
students spend 18 hours a week working
on a project
and if everything goes to plan they will
just extend their
summer internship project however we do
have some places where this is not
possible
or they get really interested in
something else
so it's not a requirement but
we also have these capstone projects
that allow our students to work
at sites like these to do a more
long-term
and in-depth project so i ask all of you
listening if you have
a project that you've always wanted to
work on and
just don't have enough time for it um
think whether one of our students might
be able to help you in either the summer
or in the school year to really make it
into an interesting and useful product
and project and base of knowledge for
the rest of the fields by
having a project for one of our students
so so far i've talked to you about this
program as if it is still taking place
at kgi
um we had our first cohort came on
campus in the fall of 2018
and they were scheduled to graduate
next month unfortunately they are not
going to be able to have their
commencement
in may as it was planned because we have
gone completely online
all of these programs were designed in
person
with the summer internship experience
but you know we always talked about well
what if the
second year was online then they could
work anywhere in the united states they
wouldn't have to work in southern
california
they could maybe telecommute to sites
all over the country and there was a
general feel that
sometime in the future we would put
portions of this
online of course one week
before spring break we were told that we
would not be coming back to campus due
to the coronavirus
and so we had nine days to convert
our entire curriculum to online
education and i will
say that i have been extremely thankful
for the
grace of our students that they have
made it work and our
faculty have made it work and so right
now we are fully online
but i'll put an asterisk because this is
fully online with
a temporary feel to it we're using zoom
we're doing the best we can but it's
still based on what we would have done
in a classroom and we are just sort of
doing it
remotely in the future
of course we can do this a lot better
and there are
um hybrid and fully online programs that
really leverage
all of the capacity of
the internet and remote computing
to do really cool things with the
students not sitting in the same room
and so i think just in the future i
don't know that we're ever going back
to um an institution where the majority
of our
classes meet in physical spaces now this
is
both exciting and scary but i think
all across the the world we're trying to
figure out how we want to do
education if there can be times when
we're told
with very little notice you can no
longer come to this physical location
and this brings up the question of
timing so right now all of our classes
are synchronous so we meet for a
specific time i teach human genomics
right now
from 10 30 to noon on mondays and
wednesdays and all of the students have
to come together
at that time to participate in the class
of course there is a model that is more
asynchronous
at kgi we do sometimes use the flipped
classroom
so for my human molecular genetics
course that of course all of the
lectures
are pre-recorded and so students can
watch those lectures whenever they
would like and we only meet to do
hands-on learning activities now
in an asynchronous model the students
would be working as a group but they
would not necessarily come together at
the same time
they would collaborate but not um
in person together
there are some advantages to the
asynchronous style of course
if you are a working clinician or if you
have a family it may be very beneficial
to schedule
uh your education around other things
that you cannot change
however the synchronous model does have
the ability for people to come together
and really do that group work
and have a chance to discuss with
faculty members and have those
spontaneous conversations
that really lead to
increased discovery and also enthusiasm
for their education
of course the programs i've talked about
are full-time programs they're very
heavy
intense two-year programs but we do need
to think about what we're doing for
certificate-based programs or just
continuing education
things that can be delivered in small
chunks
and of course we do want to do this with
very forward thinking pedagogy
which is team based learning
problem-based learning everything very
active
um and this means not just listening to
uh me lecture i know i love to lecture
because
it is my easiest way to
take all of the things in my head and
say them at the students
but i know for a fact that they don't
learn that way and so
the ability to do things that actually
challenge assumptions
make people circle back make them use
these skills
until they become second nature that is
how we're going to have to do
education and that includes people
who have not perhaps learned in this way
before
i know um through some of my
conversations with
colleagues that if you went to
medical school say 20 years ago you're
not
used to team-based active learning
flipped classroom style education so it
may be very hard to transition
learning styles but i think if we do it
the right way
it can be something that's very valuable
to people at all spectrum of their
career
and the last is to get people into the
setting where they're actually going to
work
either through internships during gaps
in the curriculum or through co-ops
where they're working in the field
getting hands-on expertise
while also getting didactic
or classroom learning to build upon what
they're seeing
at their site we are very interested in
developing more of these
partnerships so if you or someone you
know might have
a site that really wants the energy of
having students
and the ability to have someone go on a
deep dive on a project we would love to
talk to you
and so to address some of these issues
um kg i was very fortunate to
get a gift from amgen last year to build
out a new
center and this center is called
the center for training and applied
genomics the ctag
and it's really going to allow kgi to
take this full spectrum
approach where we have young people who
are interested in going into genomics
whether they're
undergraduates or high school students
evening
and given giving them master's programs
or
even phd programs and other programs to
get them into the field
as well as executive education
and continuing education for people who
are already in the field and just want
to catch up
i feel like if i blink i miss a year's
worth of genomics
discoveries and so having programming
that will keep people up to date when
they're very busy in their clinic
already
i think will be um something we can add
to this field
and so our current offerings right now
are the master of science in genetic
counseling
and i didn't talk about that program and
what makes that program very unique
today but you can get more information
on our website
the masters of science and genomic data
analytics
and we're launching this year our first
summer program in clinical genetics and
bioinformatics
we had planned a nice on-campus
two-week fully in-depth hands-on program
but unfortunately this will be
a remote online offering this summer
but it does give us the opportunity to
open it up to so many more students this
way
so we will still be running our first
summer program
in clinical genetics and bioinformatics
and of course we have
lots of other ideas that are percolating
through
and please stay tuned for any other
exciting programs we announce
so in summary genomics is changing and
it's changing
extremely fast so
how do we change education to keep up
with it and if we're going to change
healthcare we're going to have to change
education first
we also need to look at what are the
barriers to making precision medicine
the standard of care
and that is we need an expanded
workforce with training in genetics
genomics data analysis
and scientific communication and to
fully realize this potential
we have to take the full spectrum
approach we have to build the people
interested
and we have to take people working in
the clinic and also give them those
skills
that they need right now so thank you
very much for
listening and i appreciate any questions
through the chat provided by